guys let's talk first of all I love the
relationship with Robin it's really it's
really fun that Batman not thrilled to
have Robin around we're trying to make
it you know it's it's like about a boy
you know it's like it's a guy who you
know who it's about a boy as directed by
Michael Mann Jerry Maguire Life Aquatic
you know yeah he's a guy I mean
obviously you famously Batman works
alone and so when he's sort of faced and
put into this situation in this
relationship he's forced to kind of
confront a lot of issues and but he's
got this young innocent naive boy who's
you know voiced incredibly perfectly
pitch-perfect by Michael Cera and yeah
yeah he's Superman and it should be
mentioned that everybody in the cast is
so amazing yeah good tack Galifianakis
Joker rosario Dawson is Batgirl rave ray
Fiennes as as Alfred and and he's
unbelievably yeah good like research the
role Carrillo he seriously did the
extras that I'm gonna do it like Charles
Laughton and Ruggles for red gap right
like we like he like you actually
literally I came to the table with
research and then he like you had to
google that yeah for sure do that yeah
that's a great idea
now we'll one of the things I love about
your portrayal of Batman is you play him
as incredibly incredibly confident so
confident that you think he's incredibly
insecure yeah
is that the correct interpretation well
you know I think that that but Batman is
he's always you know he's an orphan and
and he's always been alone and so he's
had he's been kind of left to his own
devices and I think that there he has a
lot of issues we were talking before
that the this movie isn't just about
Batman beating his beating the enemy
it's about kind of beating his own
demons
in a way and he's kind of you know when
you have somebody who's that confident
they're oftentimes making up for other
deficiencies in other areas of their
character I always thought personally
that that will in the past no I don't
think anyone in the business does false
bravado better than you you do don't
worry I've got this and then not have it
funnier than anybody I know so you're
the perfect guy to do it well thank you
Conan I know it's like why are you
wasting everybody's time with that let's
get the stuff we don't know about all
right let's take some questions from the
audience I'm sure we have some questions
here and yes there's a gentleman it's my
questions for will I was just wondering
when we're gonna see you in your own
live-action Batman franchise boy you
know it's so funny on their way down
here we just we literally just ran into
Ben Affleck and he asked me the same
question
you know he's I think that he's got a
pretty good handle on it right now he's
obviously such an awesome actor and so
good so no time soon I don't know well
the fact I think the thing about will is
like that what I found anyway because
this is the first time you know working
with him is that he's obviously a super
funny actor but he's actually a real
actor and I think the thing in this
movie is that there there's a there's
something that's there's there's an
honesty and actors laughing no no
there's like he's like he really is
truly like honestly like there's there's
emotional stuff that this guy can do
that I just don't think people have seen
so the yeah I don't think it's that far
off the mark to have him actually do a
real Batman movie I think cuz he's real
honest like he comes to the table with
an honesty and a truth it's like really
let's do it man yeah I I think if
everyone here can just put in a hundred
thousand dollars that's a great idea
about a decent chance to make it over
what's that Joker great Joker I'd be
you're in look at that huh okay no one
bought that all right
Lego Batman movie the movie hits
theaters February oh wait we got it we
have time for one more could do one more
oh my god is that Harley Quinn hi puddin
my question is both of you guys would
you know something maybe a little bit
more doable would you be interested in
doing a lego Suicide Squad movie and
appearing in that yes above my pay grade
but uh sure that's a question for like
lawyers I think you're gonna find that
there's like there's like Dirty Dozen
aspects to this movie that I don't to
give too much away but there-there is
that yeah I think that if you're a fan
of the genre which obviously you are
thank you good see you say it's like
it's like Gautama Gustav saying you like
though and you know I think that you
will be the fans we've really rewarded
it yeah I can't give away too much yeah
like you know there's this like pork
doctor phosphorus because bookie twins
my mutant leader from the Frank Miller's
like like the we go team Anna Batman's
rogues gallery so you're gonna you're
gonna see a lot of lot of stuff aunt
Legos
the movie hits theaters February 10th
2017 thank you fresh and will that's
here please go
you